everyone uh today i'll be talking about
a very detailed survey that we did here
at healthtrack
rx about the bacterial and viral
co-infections
of sarskoff ii and uh to our knowledge
this is the largest study or largest
such study
into the co-infection rates of this
noble coronavirus
just close this slide here so the sars
column
ii which is a latest
coronavirus member the coronavirus
family
uh named as such due to the
characteristic distribution
of the spike protein on the viral
surface
is responsible for causing from mild
to fatal respiratory illnesses
in humans and when we compare the
epidemiology of this viral disease
with the other known respiratory
pathogens we find the infectivity of
this virus
is somewhere between influenza
and sars cob one which was responsible
for the 2002
stars pandemic and
since the first official declaration
of this viral outbreak at the end of
2019 the global pandemic has infected
over 29 million people the numbers that
i have here
are are out of date now
and within the united states there are
over 6.5 million confirmed cases
of the viral infection and more than 194
000
deaths and what we have seen
in recent memory the most unprecedented
mobilization of public health resources
in our fight against
this virus which has had a
great impact on our economic
and social behavior
and quite literally our knowledge of how
this virus works and the covert 19
disease that it causes our knowledge
of this virus is increasing
every day however what we find is that
the co-infections or the bacterial and
viral co-infections of sarskoff do
that's an area where our understanding
is
still quite limited now what we know
from our
experience with the other respiratory
viruses
is that the concurrent or secondary
infections
of these viruses with other bacteria
lead to an increased morbidity and
mortality
in patients and in fact the
general consensus now is that the
all the influenza pandemics of the last
century
the leading cause of mortality in those
patients were the
secondary or infections with
bacterial pathogens and this is due to
the fact that these respiratory
pathogens
both the bacteria and the viruses have
co-evolved in a manner to take advantage
of the preceding infection
so here at healthtrack rx co-infections
of respiratory pathogens is an area that
we're all
always interested in and in 2019 we had
published
us a very detailed analysis
of co-infections in
respiratory viral pathogens influenza
rsv
and others and uh the present data set
like i said uh is the largest study that
we know of
it comprised of 50 419
individual samples that were tested
between mid-march
and the beginning of august this year
and the
samples were concurrently tested for
cough ii using the tacpath coca 19 kit
from thermo fisher
and all the other pathogens both
bacterial and viral
uh respiratory pathogens were tested
on the nanofluidic open array platform
also from thermo fisher
and what we found was that the sars cost
2
infection rate at 8.4 percent
was very similar to the
all the other viral pathogens put
together at 8.2 percent
uh we found in the overall population
a bacterial infection rate of around
33 now when we do a demographic
distribution
of the sars of two infections uh
based on gender we find that the female
and male
ratio was quite similar to the overall
population set that we had
with nearly 56 females and 44
males and when we distribute the same
according to age uh what we found was
quite interesting
is that overall the younger population
that is between 20 to 50 years of age
comprised both male and female comprised
a
higher proportion as opposed to the
older population
that is 55 or 60 years and
higher
when we look at the types of
co-infections
what we find is that the distribution of
the bacterial co-infections
in both the stars of two positive and
stars of two negative population
is quite similar the numbers are you
know statistically speaking
are significantly lower in the south to
positive
population but you know still comparable
at 33 and 35 percent
however this difference is more
pronounced
in the viral co-infections where in the
sars of true positive population
the viral co-infection rates are much
lower as compared to the source of two
negative
population and
when we go actually go into the
different types of co-infections with
the bacterial co-infections
we find the usual bacterial
pathogens namely streptococcus
pneumoniae stuff
staphorious hemophilus influenza that
are represented as the
major or infecting agents
klebsiella pneumonia also but to a lower
level as compared to these other
pathogens
but what we see is that the bacterial
uh infection rates or co-infection rates
in the source
of the positive population are lower as
opposed to the sarska of two negative
population with the exception of staph
aureus
wherein the infection rates are
statistically significant
and higher in the sars of two
positive now um with the
informal discussions with other labs we
find that this is not a unique
uh observation at our end and the other
labs are
also seeing this and we find this quite
interesting and this is something that
we are looking at
much more closely now is to basically
figure out
what percentage of this is represented
by the methicillin resistant staph
aureus or mrsa
because that has a very significant
impact on the morbidity and mortality
that is associated with
respiratory infections now
we also found in the general population
we found
less than 0.1 percent infection rate of
chlamydophila pneumoniae microplasma
pneumonia and bordetella pertussis
and no co-infections with those
pathogens and that is why that's not
represented here
when we look at the viral co-infections
the majority of the pathogens as you
will see here
uh represent a less than one percent
prevalence rate and that could very well
be due to the fact
that when we started collecting this
data it was towards the end of march
and that coincides with the end
of the respiratory pathogen season or
the flu season here in the united states
and again what we see
here with the blue bars the stars of two
positive
population the co-infection rates of
these viruses
are lower as opposed to the
stars of two negative population with
the exception
of rsv and
again i apologize for some confusion
here the hsv here
is a combination of hsv one and two and
the hsv at the
end here is hsb3
or the varicella zoster virus and these
are the only two viruses
wherein we see a higher co-infection
in the sarskoff to positive population
now
the other exception that we saw was ebv
the epstein-barr virus or hsb4
and the rhinoviruses where we see
a higher than one percent prevalence
rate in the general population
a significantly higher ebv co-infection
rate was also seen
in the sars of true population and if
you go through the latest literature
what you find
is that these ebv co-infection or higher
evv co-infection rates in saarskoff two
positive patients have been reported
from other sources
also
when we look at the
age distribution of these co-infections
put together both
bacterial and viral in the sense of true
positive population what we find
is that the older population 60
plus years they are more susceptible to
these co-infections
and again
if you would recall the age distribution
of the source of to positive population
was more towards the younger side
however the co-infections are higher
in the older population and
this could very well contribute to the
poor prognosis of the coca-19 disease
that we observe in the older population
and again what we are doing right now
since as i've mentioned before
most of this study was done towards the
end of the flu season so what we are
doing
right now is that we are actively
collecting data now that fall is upon us
and
and winter is coming quite literally uh
that we will be looking at these four
infections
in much more detail and uh
will be presenting a follow-up of the
study towards the end of the
flu season in 2021 so to
summarize what we see is that the source
of true population
positive population displays a
significant co-infection
of both bacterial and viral
pathogens and generally speaking the
varico infections in the source of true
positive population
were found to be significantly lower
as opposed to the sars of two negative
population and within the viral
co-infections we find
that there the ebv or the epstein-barr
virus
co-infections are detected at a
significantly higher rate
in the sars of two positive population
when compared to the
all other respiratory viral pathogens
and amongst the bacterial pathogens in
the source of positive population we
find
a significantly higher co-infection rate
of staph aureus
and when distributed against age
what we find is that put together the
viral and bacterial co-infections
are observed at a higher rate in the
older population
that is 60 years of age and higher
as opposed to the all other age groups
and what we believe is that the data
presented here in the follow-up study
that we are doing right now
will allow for a better clinical
decision
to be made with respect to you know the
antimicrobial therapy that can be
provided to the infected subjects
for a you know for better clinical
treatment
and uh that i would like to
acknowledge the infectious disease team
here at healthtrack rx
uh namely my co-authors on this study dr
j
reddy the vp of lab operations and dr
john granger
our medical director and all the other
scientists
and laboratory personnel working here at
infectious disease in health track rx
and with that i'll take any of your
questions thank you